las vegas on eight news thursday and
it's time for puppy pig skin picks of
the week sponsored by subaru of las
vegas
amy is with us from the animal
foundation happy new year happy new year
great to see you
and you have an adorable little girl
here who is this this is baby
she's one and a half years old she
weighs 30 pounds
and she loves car rides and she can sit
she is so well behaved and she knows you
have a treat in your hand
so she will do anything for that treat
yeah what do you know about baby
um she just came to us with a strip
straight fortunately that's all we know
at this time
okay but you see you say she seems
really trainable
yes she so far since i've had her this
morning she's been
giving me her paw about 50 of the time
but she's trying
her hardest on that and she's gone down
a couple times
and she did really great on the car ride
over well let's see how she does it
picking a winning team with
two football teams this weekend it's the
saints in chicago
go for it baby pick a winner
oh wow she picked the bears yay
[Applause]
way to go baby she is such a
good girl she was so sweet she seemed
really even trained on a leash it was
wild so if you want to adopt baby first
you'll have to make an appointment
with the animal foundation you can't
just show up the number to do that
is on your screen 702-955-5901
what a sweetheart and let me tell you
guys she was
focused on those treats she knew amy had
treated her hand
she wasn't moving yeah you can tell
she's very smart and alert
i'm i'm looking at the adoption search
right now actually she is so cute
yeah i'm trying to see if she's there
still i love it
so cute john